Hey,
what's going on is bill burn it's time for the Monday morning podcast for a
Monday fucking and match 12th March 12th.
The very important day of the history of Barch.
That was the day
that was the first day slash ever wore a top hat on stage or was it Abraham
Lincoln?
What would you say that those are the most famous people who ever wore a top
hat.
Right.
Okay.
Got It.
Lincoln just get shot while he was wearing one.
So that's how everybody always draws him.
Um,
I dunno,
I feel like you gotta be a certain height.
That's,
that's tall people shit,
you know,
to have a fucking top hat and tails,
you know?
Is there anything funnier than seeing somebody short wearing tall people?
Shit.
You know,
like when you went to your prom,
that fucking little fucking five foot,
six inch fireplug showing up,
wearing the fucking tails
look like a little God damn penguin.
Um,
do people even wear tails that even have prompts anymore?
Is it considered unsafe?
I know that they're supervised and that they started to fucking book Comedians
at them.
And now who's kidding?
Who?
I guess they always should have been,
especially if you have a dog.
Okay.
Speak in a ladies and ladies,
ladies get in for free.
Um,
they never talk about that when they talk about equal pay.
Huh?
Ladies' night.
Leave your money at home and bring your snatch cause you're not paying for shit.
Right.
They don't talk about that through that.
All the nightclubs,
they get in for free,
for free.
Um,
actually what they really mean,
don't they really mean beautiful women,
beautiful women.
Get it for free,
you know,
mediocre to ugly women.
Then they just start going like,
hey,
you know,
we're uh,
we're kind of full right now.
And what does that do?
That causes of movement.
I went to a club the other night and they said it was full and there wasn't,
you know,
I know that because all of a sudden these other women who yeah,
they were skinnier.
Yeah.
They had better bone structure.
They were better looking at it.
They wouldn't lend me and they let them in.
Yeah.
This isn't right.
MMM.
What do people who aren't good looking just go to admit that they're not good
looking and just realize that they're going to have to walk through another door
in life.
It makes you stronger.
You know,
I'd love to have sympathy for you,
but I'm a bald,
redheaded mail,
so I mean,
you fucking preaching to the choir.
You know,
you think the club wasn't full when I showed up.
Well,
will make me my own room.
Wow.
It's just the fucking poor me era of human beings is we ignore a real,
real,
real
shit,
real shit that's going on.
What kind of real shit is going on,
Bill?
I don't know.
I don't pay attention.
I know there's gotta be something more important than fucking bathrooms,
right?
We already got bathrooms.
Pick one.
I'm sorry.
Okay.
Anyways,
plowing ahead here.
Yeah.
You're probably wondering why I'm in such a weird fucked up movie.
I'm really not in a weird phone.
I'm in a good mood.
This is me in a good mood.
I cleaned up my office,
finally,
finally put things in their proper place.
Um,
found a lot of shit that I thought I lost or misplaced or even forgot that I
even had.
Now I'm a minimalist will be like,
well,
that's sense what you need to get.
You need to get rid of all this.
You to get real low as it is.
Where does it go?
They're minimalist.
Okay.
Into the ocean.
Into a fucking dump.
Okay.
Stop acting like every fucking post that you have out there.
You're going to go sell on craigslist and someone's going to want to buy it.
Okay.
Isn't it more environmentally sound to be a hoarder
rather than sending all your shit to the dump?
Poisoning the soil.
You have it contained within your own apartment or house
or a or or Cabana Oak guesthouse,
depending on your living situation.
Yeah.
You can't tell me ever since Oj that when you're in a guest house,
you can't.
You can't be the guest and think,
what if the fucking person who owns this kills their spouse and somebody else
who happened to be there?
Wait,
am I going to be the person who happens to be there?
All right.
Note to self the entire time.
I'm a guest
in this guy's house.
Just make sure I'm always wearing,
supposed to be,
how will I know where I'm supposed to be?
I'm just going to avoid this fucking guy and pay the rent on time.
That's what Oj did.
I have a lot of people talk about the bad that he did.
Okay.
Which is pretty obvious at this point.
Um,
yeah,
but the good that he did is I think the behavior of people in guest houses.
I bet if you were able to chart it,
if you've got an algorithm or whatever is these number crunching,
crunching people do,
they would find that the behavior of the Keto Caitlin's of the world
dramatically improved after Oj,
you know?
Okay.
Well I guess you can't say killed those two people.
He was acquitted.
Um,
it's fucked up.
How the fuck you supposed to say that?
I,
you know,
I don't,
I think I just talked myself into a corner.
Look at the bird then I fucking burnt out there.
Okay.
You know,
a lot of,
you know,
I'm just sitting there looking at that fucking thing.
How that fat fuck that bird just flew the way it just did.
I think it's all about the legs,
I think.
Yeah.
You know,
I bet if you got a fucking really skinny person,
right?
Had a beer belly and they had little bird legs.
Yeah.
Nah,
I still wouldn't work would it?
You know what?
I bet you could get them to try if you talked to him long enough.
If you talk to him long enough,
you know,
C'mon Dude,
look at he,
you shaped just like a burden and you're smarter than that fucking thing.
Give it a jump.
Come on.
I'm sorry.
Anyway,
so this is Sunday afternoon.
Uh,
I just put my absolutely darling daughter in the other room for a nap,
so I got the fucking big brother camera going here.
Where the fuck is it?
A Shit with a flux.
The camera.
God dammit.
I just fucking had this thing.
I was killing it.
I had everything going the way I needed it to be going.
Oh,
there it is.
There it is.
What is she doing?
Oh,
she's sleeping Rocca by Qd and the other room
something someday.
Then I'll get a broom,
clean up all the shit that fell on the floor,
and then you'll come out and deal with some more.
Oh,
dad,
can you stop singing your nerd songs?
Um,
anyways,
uh,
you know,
it's fucking amazing is I'm getting my Invisalign off,
allegedly just like Oj,
allegedly.
I'm getting my Invisalign off this Wednesday.
I can't fucking wait.
I'm on train number 13.
It was projected to take 16 weeks,
but I had these fuckers in the whole time.
I did my half on my stand up sets.
I left them in spitting all over the fucking stage.
I just wanted to get it over with.
Right.
That's a big thing in life when they would,
something sucks.
You just get it over with.
Kay.
You get tossed overboard in the ocean.
You know what I mean?
You see that shark fin.
Don't swim away from it.
You swim at it head first,
get it over with it.
What do you say that show gain?
Um,
anyways,
I'm getting my Invisalign off and then they give me a mouth Gad.
Uh,
so for the rest of my life when I go to sleep,
I just popped in the mouth guard and then I'm fine and the ship will stay the
same.
And uh,
and it's also cool because,
you know,
occasionally I will grind my teeth at night because I'm a lunatic or I'm
stressed.
I don't know what it is,
but it's something I've done ever since I was a little kid.
Um,
so anyway,
so it all worked out and I'll fuck a worked out and I highly recommended and
they're not paying me to tell you guys that fucking Invisalign is the shit.
But uh,
it's the shit,
you know,
considering what they used to do,
put all that Barb wire and you fucking mouth,
you know,
then God forbid you got into a fight.
It was just like you were a fucking bleed.
All someone to do is just punch you right in the mouth.
I would playing,
we were playing killed a man with them,
not kill them out with the ball.
That's what we used to call that game.
You just pick up the football and start running and the other half your grade
would tackle you and then you just coughed it up and someone else got it.
It was fucking great and played a toll.
We played it everyday.
Outdoor recess,
just a button you come in,
you when you weren't even sore,
your body was brand new.
He had a big puffy coat on.
That's all you needed.
Um,
so we were playing football one time and uh,
it was right around the time,
you know,
junior high when kids started getting braces.
And I remember this Kid Sean,
he got somehow hit in the mouth and when he got up like the wires that go from
like,
you know,
you know the,
each tooth they had like a,
like a little fucking central hub where the wires would go through and like the
thing had like popped off,
the wired popped off.
Those things are still glued on.
That's right.
And he had like two wires sticking straight out of his mouth
and maybe even getting up,
like making this weird noise and he was bleeding.
And then we all just standing there like,
ah,
somebody get applied.
Um,
but now they got Invisalign and it's tremendous.
And you two and 13,
well it depends on how fucked up your teeth are and how much you're willing to
wear them because I know somebody else that's getting them and doesn't want to
wear them all the time.
So she's given into the fact that it's going to take,
you know,
like a year and a half or some shit.
And now it's just like,
why wouldn't you get it over with?
And she was just like,
why wouldn't you just fuck off?
And I was like,
fine.
Fair enough.
Who am I to tell you
how to fix your fucking dentition?
All right.
I'm just,
you know,
I'm excited.
I want other people to be excited.
Hey,
his son to be excited about,
I finally watched,
I watched two Bruins games this weekend.
Yeah,
it,
Eh,
I finally saw Rick Nash Plan with the Bruins spake physical presence,
scored a goal on a Saturday.
Now matinee game,
those games usually suck,
right?
Cause if fucking teams tired,
they're just waken up.
They used to like sh there's still shaken off a hangover and all of a sudden
that dropping the puck is a bunch of kids there and shit.
It feels like,
it feels like a charity game,
you know,
it doesn't feel like the season.
Uh,
but they played a wild one on Saturday,
seven to four.
They won.
They were up two to nothing looking like it was going to be nice smooth fucking
time.
And then,
uh,
the hawks gave a seal right there,
Fred.
Then it was two to two.
I came out with three,
two,
three,
four,
five,
six,
four,
seven,
four.
Right.
I think that's what it was.
And then today,
like to fucking,
you know,
I thought we were going to a,
we tied it up and thought we had the goddamn thing one.
And then shower law.
I know the Patrick Sharp took a stick to the face of Charisse and we'd get a
shower in the box for four minute fucking major for the rest of the Goddamn
game.
Right.
A double minor I should say.
And then,
uh,
of course they go out there and the fucking,
it reminds me when we lost the Stanley Cup to him,
but we were like,
oh,
there is going to be a game seven now there isn't,
it's over.
Um,
they did that fucking Patrick Kane,
Jesus Christ,
guises sniper.
Um,
so I'm going to try to watch some more of the gains,
but I mean I've watched so many fucking games in the last 10 years,
so it didn't feel like I was away that long and I still knew most of the team
cause I've been watching,
uh,
looking at the stats and all of that shit.
Um,
so I dunno,
I guess I'll try it.
I don't know what we're not,
and I got the kid,
man.
It's just,
it's fucking hard,
man.
I haven't been able to watch my Celtics.
My Bruins patriots are easy cause it's like once a week,
you know.
So,
um,
anyways,
I'm just fucking,
I'm meandering right now because I'm waiting for the,
uh,
all the reeds and all that bullshit to come in because there's always,
I have 50,000 fucking things I have to do today.
Even on a Sunday.
This is a day arrest.
Even God rested on Sunday.
I'm working harder than God people.
Um,
I shouldn't have said that.
You know,
this fucking person sent me this,
this,
I don't know,
this fucking thing with this guy was convinced that I was possessed by Satan and
his eye for cinematography was incredible.
The way he was breaking down something that he did.
He got every fucking thing that we would doing right.
He just had the motivation rock.
He was like,
this is hypnotic.
They're trying to hit the Taj here.
It was all the serve Satan.
And it's like,
no,
it's not the serve Satan.
It's so I could sell tickets.
The reason why there's no crowd shots is because I feel your brain resets every
time they cut to the fucking crowd,
and then you've got to try to draw him in again.
When you go to a fucking standup show,
you're not looking at the comedian and then turning around and looking at people
laughing every fucking eight seconds.
That would be a shitty experience.
So I'm trying to recreate the live experience.
That's all I'm doing.
I'm not trying to serve,
uh,
you know,
the guy down under all right.
With my standup special,
I do that effortlessly the way I live my life anyways.
Um,
but it's fucking this youtube video.
This guy's comparing like fucking,
he goes,
look at the [inaudible] x.
So kind they use black and white and they fucking do all this shit was really a,
it was really insane.
Um,
my favorite part was when he told his kid and knock it off.
I'm like,
all right,
he's a good dad.
Hey,
knock it off.
Um,
but yeah,
uh,
anyways,
you're going to get that right.
I guess if you put a fucking special out,
you're going to get some shit like that.
Who gives a fuck about my standup specials?
You know,
it was awesome.
Last night I stayed in with my lovely,
beautiful,
gorgeous wife and we hung in and,
uh,
I started to watch peaky blinders and you don't know nothing about no robbery.
Right?
She's like,
I don't want to watch this every bill,
you're wide enough.
I have a difficult time,
enough understanding.
You forget about these fucking people.
Right.
So I was like,
okay,
fair enough.
So then we were scrolling through and,
uh,
I look for the nice guys once again,
Netflix.
Can you make my year and get the Nice guys starring Russell Crowe and,
um,
God,
Jesus.
Wow.
How can I forget this guy's name?
The guy from drive,
the guy from la La land.
I'll remember it later.
I always
the fuck is his name.
He's fucking hilarious in that movie too.
You know.
Fuck this.
Hang on a second.
I'm going to hit pause.
I to get this guy's name,
sorry.
Ryan Gosling.
Yeah,
they're fucking hilarious in that move.
Ryan Gosling's hilarious.
But also Cora was hilarious.
It's such an underrated comedy and it reminds me of one of my favorite comedies
of all time,
midnight run as far as I feel like the comedy,
so much of it,
their reactions and the way they're doing things,
it's,
it comes from a real place.
I don't mind Wacky,
I don't mind absurd or any of that bullshit,
but,
uh,
I fucking love that movie and I'm so I looked it up and for whatever reason,
Netflix has every fucking movie just about on this streaming surface,
the biggest streaming service in the world,
world world world.
Right.
But they don't have that one.
So I'm like,
fuck.
And we scrolled down and then they had Fellman Luis and I was just like,
man,
I am not,
I literally not seen that movie since I saw it when it came out in the movies.
And uh,
oh,
is that a great fucking movie?
Okay.
Fucking great God damn movie.
And it still holds up.
And now with all this,
me too.
Shit,
you watch it now and it,
it's,
it's more relevant than ever.
And every guy in there was just this piece of shit hitting on him.
Like the guy who plays Gina Davis has a husband,
Christopher McDonald,
he fought,
he fucking steals every scene that he's in.
Yeah,
you got to,
you got to watch it again.
What did they tell him?
That his wife might be involved in her murder,
murder.
He just goes,
what?
W
Just the way he does.
I'm going to be,
I'm butchering it.
He's fucking hilarious in that movie.
And uh,
we watched an aroma in the end,
you know,
I don't want to ruin the ending for people who haven't seen it,
but uh,
you know,
anything that you know is a little nod to vanishing point.
You got to love that.
Have you ever seen vanishing point?
That's one of the first like anti hero.
It was during that,
not the first,
but during that era of the anti hero,
like up until then,
I guess with movies and Shit,
it was always like,
you know,
the guy with white hat and who's kidding who the white skin was always like the
fucking hero.
He was always trying to do the right thing.
He didn't rob,
he didn't steal and he was a fucking hero.
And if you stole and you were a piece of shit,
uh,
you are the black cat,
you were the bad guy.
You know what I mean?
I would say that they'd put minorities in those roles.
But way back then,
I didn't think they did that.
They just had like,
they even had white people playing like native Americans and Asians,
even Asians.
I remember that when I posted that thing from fucking Hawaii five o and they had
that fucking white dude and they did some that was eyes to try to make him look.
He just looked weird.
Um,
which was really strange because they had all those,
I don't know if they will hope Asian Hawaiian on what the fuck they were,
but I mean they had plenty of people who weren't white on that show.
I don't know.
It didn't make any sense.
But anyways,
you've got to love Jack Lawrence Mercury Marquee.
Um,
I liked the first one.
They'd had the 67 that he had or the 66.
That was a mean fucking looking car.
Um,
anyways,
but we sat and we watched that movie and uh,
it's still,
it's just still holds up.
It's still fucking holds up.
This is a time when usually I would start doing some reads,
but I don't fucking have any
filming my reads Jesus.
Bill.
Why would you make such a bad fucking joke?
You know,
I can't even sign into my fucking Gmail right now.
I don't know what the problem is.
Oh,
Instagram instinct.
I'm inching closer to getting on Instagram.
I figured out what my password is and now they're like,
God has been too many fucked up attempts to get into your account.
I'm like,
all right,
that was me.
But there's nobody to say that too.
So they go in and send this fucking code to you and then they never sent it.
Well,
who's kid who they send me something back in September and I never fucking
responded.
So now I think they're looking at my,
uh,
you know,
my account,
like it's fucked up or some shit.
I have no idea.
But anyways,
who gives a shit enough about that?
Um,
oh,
so thank you to everybody who,
uh,
who came out to my shows of Vancouver,
Jesus Christ and I have a good time.
I had such a fucking great time,
uh,
performing up there,
such a beautiful city and all that.
And um,
this woman started running down to the stage.
She was yelling something about how lesbians were better at something and I was
just like,
why do I don't know what you're talking about and you know,
and I was being an asshole,
you know,
make it fun of all that and me to shit.
You know,
just,
you know,
feminists that you did just so easy to get mad.
How do you not do it?
It's just so fucking tempting as a comic.
So I'm up to it just saying this fucking ridiculous ignorant shit and
everybody's laughing,
including all the rest of the women there.
Cause he know what I'm saying is so fucking ridiculous.
They know.
I don't believe it.
Right.
But nowadays there's,
there's always the,
uh,
you know,
Franny face value in the fucking crowd,
right?
You've got to fucking take everything.
Like,
did he mean,
now I'm offended,
now I'm offended.
So I dunno what the fuck she was doing.
She started like marching down towards the stage and all this security cave and
just got her in a way.
And next note.
Next thing I knew she was being escorted out,
which sucked because that meant the fun was over a curb.
I heard people,
People's guides of preds and came out to the show.
They were trying to just people walking out saying that she was a plant.
That was funny.
Is that
like I got that kind of time and money to fly an actor up to fucking Vancouver
to interrupt my show.
It's just like at that point when I just hired somebody to write me better
material,
um,
who knows?
I don't fuck,
I have no idea.
I don't know why people always think that
that's such an old show Biz thing to have a plant in the crowd.
But people used to do it.
They did used to do it.
So I guess it's fair that they,
that they,
uh,
that they think that.
But anyways,
so she got kicked out.
I never kick anybody out on the show and it wasn't my call either.
They just fucking escorted her out.
Um,
which I thought was funny after,
I mean,
I kind of felt bad.
I was like,
well that's,
you know,
we've been fun.
If she stuck around,
I could hear it.
Some more of a fucking crazy theories,
you know,
I don't know.
I don't,
there's this,
and I had,
I had another two women walked out on my show when I was down in the Improv.
Now if I was some sort of thinking man,
it would be like,
well,
hey bill,
that's two incidents the one week,
maybe it's shoe.
But you know,
I really don't think it is.
I just think that the,
uh,
the extreme left
are,
are out of their fucking minds now.
And they have this thing where if you,
if that the,
there's only one way to think and it's their way and there's only certain
subjects you can joke about.
And if they don't think that you should be joking about it,
that they're,
they're just gonna really just behave like children
was funny when they got up and walked out when I was at the Improv,
like people were going to care.
Um,
I dunno.
Hey,
you know what?
You know what?
It's just the world that we're living in,
Huh?
Just as overly sensitive fucking time that we live in.
And so anyways,
uh,
okay,
the fuck am I going to get these reeds 80 just see Trump is going to go talk to
Kim Jong.
They're going gonna go hang out.
So I actually looked up the fucking story,
right?
I looked at story and we see if I can find this shit.
And my first thought when I saw that picture side decide is like,
you know,
Trump gets way too much shit for his fucking hair.
Do the picture they have on the Google news is,
hey,
it looks good to me.
You know,
I think it was bad for a long time where he had,
he did have a comb over,
but since then hair plugs got way better and I think he filled it in,
but he likes having the big swooping thing cause I think that's part of his
look.
But I think that's all his hair but whatever.
But Kim Jong UN's haircut.
How in the fuck you say,
Jesus Christ,
I don't want to sabotage this meeting,
but my God,
he has like a Joseph Stalin meets Moe Howard with a little bit of John Travolta.
All in the same,
yeah,
all in the same fucking
okay.
Haircut.
It's incredible.
Really?
Yes.
It's like the kind of haircut like a wrestler.
You know,
what have they wanted to make a splash?
Like,
oh my God,
who the fuck is this guy?
Um,
but anyways,
isn't it?
You mentioned the balls and me just sitting here and fucking completely bald.
Sitting there trash in these people's haircuts.
I gave Trump a naughty,
that nautical or Septra compared to what?
Compared to what I'm fucking dealing with,
I guess.
Although I think I look better than a,
Hey,
well let's do that.
Let's do that on the Photoshop.
You know,
when they go,
who wore it best,
you know,
do a fucking Trump,
me and Kim Jong Un and just vote worst haircut
and fuck all you assholes.
Who picked me just to be cunt.
I respect it,
but fuck you too.
All right.
CIA Director,
Mike Pompeo has defended Donald Trump's decision to meet North Korean leader.
Kim Jong saying the president understands the risk.
Uh,
I actually think it's fucking great that he's doing this.
This should happen more.
Go talk it out before a bunch of people fucking die.
You're lunatics.
He said,
Mr. Trump isn't doing this for theater.
He's going there to solve a problem despite chief told a Fox News Sunday.
Uh,
it's funny that he's a spa,
a spa,
a spy,
and he's going on the fucking news.
The president has said the summit could produce the greatest deal for the world.
What else do what he say?
He's been saying that that's how it got him in the office.
Everything's great,
but critics have warned that it's a tops tog scope.
Poorly.
The two nations will be in a worse position than before.
Uh,
the,
it's the political gamble of the 21st century that the tricky task of preparing
for the Trump Kim summit.
Why is everybody so like,
why is it better if that the two of them don't talk?
Says no sitting US president has ever met a North Korean leader.
Mr. Trump reportedly accepted the offer to do so on the spot when it was really
relayed by South Korea,
South Korean envoys on Thursday,
taking his own administration by surprise.
Let me ask you this,
please tell me they're not going to meet some fucking Italian restaurant in the
village.
Okay.
And if any point Kim Jones says,
I need to go to the bathroom.
All right,
you better.
You better have something down by your ankles.
That's all I'm saying.
Um,
anyways,
attempts to negotiate aid for just disarmament deals have failed repeatedly
since 2003 when the north pulled
out of the nuclear non proliferation treaty.
Mr Pavio told CBSC administration had it's eyes wide open to the challenge of
dealing with North Korea.
Um,
I gotta be honest with you,
I don't understand what the fucking problem is.
Okay.
Like why are there so we have like economic sanctions on them.
Is that why there are people are starving and we have that on them because they
were part of the communist expansion.
You know,
there's gotta be a better way to do it.
We gotta,
you know,
economic sanctions.
We,
why don't you go the other way?
Why don't we ever go the other way and just become like the,
the,
the fucking,
you know,
just be like a good shit,
fight the guy to the Superbowl.
Get him some whores,
you know,
then he,
then he doesn't want to blow this place up.
He,
I can't fucking blow that up.
Yeah,
I bought to the football game.
I got my dick sucked.
Well what are we doing here?
I liked those guys.
Right.
Is that going?
The Bruins in the rangers hated each other and then they all played on the same
team and they went and they played the Russians and all of a sudden the rivalry
fucking died.
That's what you do.
These people they got,
they got to hang out.
You know,
I don't know how good that will be for the rest of us.
Cause then they're probably like joined forces.
I have no fucking idea.
Um,
yeah
sweat.
Don't read the news.
I mean,
Princess Diana's iconic minefield walk.
What the fuck is this about?
Okay.
How slow news Newsday is it that they're,
they're going to bring this shit up.
I mean then it was like she died to what?
Rosa parks before Rosa parks.
There was a 15 year old girl.
Okay.
From hero to big friend.
Is Bernie Sanders running for president?
Five women.
Five countries.
Five babies.
It sounds like a bad movie,
doesn't it?
Demand Brussel can't stop.
Brussels can't stop talking about.
That's the winner right there.
Who's this guy's Brussels.
Can't stop the man at the heart of the Bra Brussels Saga Saga.
I have no idea what this is about.
The European Commission has denied allegations of cronyism after a protege of
its president shown collage junk.
NEP was given one of the most powerful jobs in the EU civil service.
He hasn't.
Everybody hooks everybody up in politics.
Mark Martins sell.
Mayer has been appointed secretary general,
general of the commission off not Martin.
Satan May.
Mailer sell mayor.
Okay.
The organization that monitors where the countries are sticking to,
he use rules,
dreams up new laws and runs the Brexit talks day to day.
Yeah.
Who is he?
He's at 40 something low.
Who gives a fuck.
This is why I can't pay.
Who,
who cares?
I don't care.
I actually stopped carrying the middle of that.
Um,
all right.
I guess I have to hit pause at this point cause I don't have any my fucking
advertising,
right.
No bullshit wellness.
Can I talk to you about Oh,
you know what,
my fucking shoulder is doing great.
I did yoga for 20
minutes before my shoulder was like,
you know,
get a little like,
hey,
take it easy there.
Huh?
Um,
I got weightlifting going again a little bit.
I got to get in shape.
Girls,
you know the pink,
Oh my God,
you had a girl,
one pounders.
I got the baby blue fucking five pounders and uh,
I don't know.
At some point I'm going to work back up to the iron,
but at this point,
oh my,
uh,
all my weight training.
What's the Shit I grabbed?
Looks like it's made out of play dough but a fucking site.
Cause I told you guys and you know,
I'm turning 50.
I don't know if I brought that up 50,000 fucking times,
but I'm turning 50 in June and uh,
I'm gonna get into the best shape of my life.
That's what I plan on doing a,
that's my plant,
whether I do it or not,
I have no idea.
Not the best shape of my life.
Best shape of my fucking,
like the last 10 years.
Cause matter how good a shape I get in,
you know,
the parts of 50 years old.
Right.
You know,
they was trying to say that shit.
they used to do that shit when it's just like,
you know,
he did a test set,
I'm 50,
but my fucking legs of 40.
It's like,
no,
they're not.
And those are your,
those are all original parts.
Okay.
Unless you lost a leg and then they stuck a new one on there when you were 10,
then that leg would be 40 years old.
The prosthetic.
All right.
That was negative.
All right,
let me,
uh,
let me hit pause here.
All right,
I'm back.
It was half a second in your life,
but uh,
all right,
I got it.
Oh Geez.
We've got a new advertisers here.
My bookie over there,
my bookie.
For those of you people out there like to gamble on sports,
I like these guys because they're not trying to act like,
you know,
this is a game of skill.
They're like your bookie.
My bookie.
Okay.
Uh,
my bookie.
Hey guys,
it's time to talk to you about the boatload of money you can make this week by
Betty.
Get my bookie.
Oh Jesus Christ.
And it is,
I always get you,
if you haven't checked him out,
this is the perfect time to get into the action.
The Mat,
the madness of March is here.
All right guys,
gamble responsibly.
Cause you know,
I'm going to bet you know I bet on stuff.
Okay.
But let's just don't put your house,
okay?
This is what the bookies are.
No different.
Dan,
then ar 15.
Okay.
It's,
it's all how you use them.
All right?
If you haven't checked them out,
this is the perfect time to get into the action.
The Madness of March is here.
Put down some money in score big on college hoops.
Join me and thousands of online players and start betting at my bookie.
Dot.
Agee.
I don't bet online,
I wouldn't even know how to fucking begin to do this.
I can't even get into my own Instagram account.
That's just a generic line that they give every host.
Okay,
but you know if you hear Yo,
this is where you can fucking gamble.
If you think you know what you're talking about,
put your money where your mouth is.
Are you sick and tired of getting the runaround when you asked for your pay out?
I would only recommend a service
to I to you,
I guess it was supposed to say to you,
that's been good to me and our listeners since my first fucking read.
They even have in game live betting so you can even place a bet after tip off a
chase.
Your money join now in my bookie will match your first deposit with a 50% bonus.
You can even enter for a chance to win their million dollar bracket challenge.
Somebody always hits that right there.
Use Promo Code burpee.
You are are to activate,
offer,
visit my bookie today.
Play win and get paid or play loose and get yelled at.
Those are your options.
Um,
yeah.
What are you gonna you know,
I want to how the mob thinks about what these fucking people are doing.
A's cutting in our action.
Ovi But uh,
being bad at,
but um,
I'm actually,
I'm actually going to gamble.
You know,
I should,
I should use my bookie.
Why not?
I'll throw a fucking hundred bucks on March madness.
When does it start?
Who's playing?
Huh?
That's it.
Most people say what's the gay bath or fucking they'll throw.
See.
Noted.
All right.
The Black Tux.
Everybody.
This isn't the me too black Tux that everybody wore.
This is just the one for fucking regular people who didn't take the dick out at
work or need to prove that they didn't.
Okay.
This is for classy people,
not these animals here in Hollywood.
All right.
I tried to make things up with a certain colored shirt rather than just in their
behavior.
Okay.
This is a class act here.
This is civilian outside of Hollywood,
black Tuxedos.
All right.
For more than a year.
Now.
I've been talking about the black tux.com the black Tux,
it never gets old because they always have new and exciting styles for your next
big event,
whether are going for a stylist selected outfit or building a custom look.
The Black Tux has tons of new suits and Tuxedos to choose from for your big
spring events.
The Black Tux is always changing up to looks.
Making it fun to try out different suits and Tuxedos.
Even if you have your own suits,
switching it up with the black Tux is always a great idea.
Yeah,
it is a great idea.
It's something different.
It comes all steamed and ready to go.
You throw it on your twirl,
your fucking lady around the dance floor.
You come home,
you give it back to them,
done over.
Um,
well,
it's kind of creepy.
And then someone else.
Where's it to something else?
Just imagine all the memories that are in there,
right?
It's like a fucking,
I don't know what it is.
Some reason I thought,
no,
I can't see what it just I and
I thought,
no,
I just thought I'll tell you later what I was thinking of and with their new fit
algorithm,
you don't have to awkwardly measure yourself or ask a friend for help.
Yeah,
the Black Tux does it for you.
Plus the Black Tux free home.
Try on,
lets you see the fit and feel the quality of your suit months before your event.
After ordering your suit will arrive for 14 days before your event.
And remember how simple returns are where it turned heads since.
Send it back three days after your event.
Shipping is free both ways.
Stand out at your event for the right reasons with the Black Tux to get a $20
$20 off your purchase,
visit the black tux.com/burr that's the black tux.com/burr for $20 off your
purchase.
The black Tux premium rental suits and Tuxedos delivered.
This is what you can wear where after when all your money on my books.
Look at dad tying everything together.
Oh,
oh look who's back.
Ah,
but Oh,
don't do me on days.
Be on days putting on your fucking black Tux.
Doo Doo Doo doot.
[inaudible] me undies.
Why did she suck on those Cox?
Um,
because she wanted apart in a movie.
She was in,
not one,
not two,
but three because she played that fucking game.
And now how the fuck is she ever going to get any more work?
Um,
you know how a horse going to handle this whole fucking post me to
some women probably.
They got fuck it.
I'll do it.
Get over here.
You're fucking wart hog.
Um,
anyways,
you've heard me talk about me undies and you know that I'm a big believer in
their product.
They're the perfect balance of comfortable fit.
Every month they have a new and exciting prince and they arrive at your door in
a fun bag.
Uh,
brds uses Lenzing micro modal modal in their underwear.
It's a sustainably sourced,
I don't know what that means.
Naturally soft fiber that does that mean after you cut down a tree and make this
underwear,
you plant another one.
A modal tree.
Morrell naturally soft fiber that starts with the beechwood trees and ends with
the most amazing fabrics you've ever experienced.
The results have been downright dreamy.
It's incredible that this,
these things are made out of wood.
You know,
how do you not get splinters in your fucking ball bag?
They're not little picket fence along your Tane Mian.
He's adventurous prints or design and designs are all limited edition and new
patterns are released every few weeks on a rolling basis.
100% satisfaction guaranteed.
Me undies guarantees you,
you will love your undies or your money back.
How the fuck do they keep coming up with new designs is beyond me.
Beyond these assure your love your underwear,
they offer a 100% satisfaction guarantee.
If you don't love your first pair,
you don't love it,
you'll get a full refund.
This is a no brainer and you get to keep the underwear is willing to do it.
Take it back,
wash it and give it to somebody else.
Get 20% off you.
A pair of the most comfortable underwear underwear you'll ever put on to get
your 20% off your first pair of free shipping.
100% satisfaction guaranteed.
Go to me undies.com/ [inaudible] that's me on [inaudible] dot com slash uh,
we got another one.
Simply safe.
I've got some exciting news.
A home security company I've worked with since they were Jadip.
I've watched them transform into the fastest growing home security company in
the nation protecting over 2 million people.
Why didn't I invest in this?
Okay,
well,
they just released their brand new home security system.
The all new simply safe.
This system has been completely rebuilt and redesign.
They've added new safeguards to protect against power outages down.
Why Fi cut land lines,
bats,
hammers and everything in between.
What
bats?
Like the fucking things that fly hammers.
What do they mean?
Like fiv shown up with weapons.
I don't know what that means.
Uh,
the all new simply safe was redesigned to be practically invisible with the
power sensors with power sensors so small,
you'll hardly notice them.
You know who you know when intruders,
oh,
you know who will intrude is not when you know who will intrude is they're going
to notice all that shit.
Okay?
This is what truly remarkable.
This is what's truly remarkable to me.
Simply safe spent years building this system.
They added so much,
but you still get the same fair and honest price.
24 seven protection for only $15 a month and there's no contract.
It's smaller,
faster and stronger than anything they've built before,
but supplies very limited visit simply safe bur bur r.com now to order that
simply safe bird.com protected.
Protect your home and family today.
Simply safe.
[inaudible] dot com you know what I was wondering like,
can you also use that shit to like catch your roommates stealing your shit?
Yo go into your fuck I robe.
All right lastly but not leastly.
stamps.com stamps.com never closes.
Print postage for letters or packages at your convenience.
24 seven mail,
everything from postcards to envelopes to packages,
domestic or international.
Creates your stamp.com account in minutes online with no equipment to lease.
And no longterm commitments.
Click,
print and mail,
and you're done.
They'll send you a digital scale automate.
They'd automatically calculates exact postage,
stamps.com believe and help you decide the best class of male based on your
needs.
I use that to your needs.
I feel for me,
second class would be the baddest,
I use stamps.com and I would be using it this year when I come up with a poster
for my fucking tour when I ship them out to these venues.
And I'm a moron if I can figure it out how to use it.
So can you,
and right now you too can enjoy the stairs.
Dot.
Curb service.
I don't know why I keep yawning with this special offer that includes a four
week trial plus postage and a digital scale.
Go to stamps.com click on the microphone,
stop the homepage and type in burr that stamps.com enter burr.
Um,
okay.
I just realized I left the monitor and the other room.
I don't want my daughter to wake up without me.
All right,
hang on.
Uh,
you know what?
She's still sleeping and I just realized that it's not
four 15.
It's five 15.
So I need to wake her up.
I hate having to wake her up,
but I got to do that or else she's going to throw it all off.
All right.
They've got to hit pause again.
Hitting pause again.
Ah,
right.
I'm back.
Hey,
he's back.
Oh right.
I was all set to launch into why Postmates sucks is I finally downloaded it onto
my phone,
the APP,
and I was like,
all right,
I'm gonna do what all the kids are doing.
Baba Baba,
Baba fog,
a door or window in order the food and some fucking is going to show up and they
haven't,
you know,
they can't fucking ring a doorbell anymore.
They're sitting there,
they're texting you that they're outside of the head.
Knock on the fucking door.
Um,
so anyways,
I've used it twice.
Same place.
Okay.
The first fucking guy say,
I said I that I live on fucking 9 million,
main street,
north main street.
He went to the south main street.
He's just like God,
blah,
blah.
K nine miles from your house,
blah,
let to fog toad Santa.
We talked,
he was actually a good shit.
And I,
I sat there blaming myself going,
I probably fucked it up.
I just signed up a bottle,
all his fucking shit in it turned out I didn't fuck up.
I put my right set of coping in the day.
They fucked up.
I still tip the guy,
right?
I got to need to be liked.
He was a good guy,
whatever.
So I ordered again,
same fucking place and I'm waiting and I'm waiting and then I'm looking and it
says it's going to be here at like six.
And I'm like,
fine,
you know,
but I can't negotiate it.
And then fucking,
I dunno,
I hit something and it said,
oops,
it's been a problem you order can't go through.
So I was just like,
hey fucking fuck Postmates and all this shit and ate something else.
And in the middle of prepping that,
uh,
the doorbell rings and my order came,
so I don't know what I did.
So I apologize to Postmates for all the Shit I just said about him walking
around my house.
Evidently I fucked it up.
I went back to some other screens.
All I knew was I couldn't tell if I ordered it and had gone through.
I don't,
I don't know.
Do you know it doesn't take much to fucking,
you know,
sorry,
I'm checking my password.
He can't fucking think and type at the same time.
It doesn't take much to throw me off.
That's all I'm saying.
All right.
So whatever Postmates is fine.
Okay.
All right.
Uh,
build toward dates.
Second and third late shows added to some of these dates.
Oh,
nice.
Nice.
Nice baby bull bull bull bull to Doodoodoo.
Oh,
fucking big head's.
Got a fucking tour.
He's still,
when I'm going to be in Kitchener,
Ontario match seventh we added a lake show.
I'm sorry,
March 17th St Patty steak to a little Rah Rah Rah and green alligator and the
substance of 10 then the long neck goose,
Conor McGregor and a fucking something.
All right.
It's also Oklahoma.
March 30th where do we have San Antonio?
We edit a show.
My Art.
March 31st we added a late show in Pittsburgh.
April 6th,
we added a late show and Cincinnati April 7th is I go through the fucking and
I've CCED AFC central field,
AFC central division.
Uh,
Nashville.
We added a late show April 21st,
um,
San Francisco.
I'm there the fort may 14,
15,
16 and 17,
uh,
17th is the only day with tickets left.
Look at you fucking guys showing up for the ball.
Franco,
thank you that I'm doing the three arena in Dublin,
Ireland.
And then I'm doing Royal Albert Hall in London,
England.
Can you believe that?
And if you fucking think that I'm not setting up an old Ludwig kid there during
the fucking day and playing a bunch of Zeppelin when the place is empty,
uh,
you,
you don't know me,
I'm going to do that unless they tell me I can't.
Then I'll be like,
oh,
sorry,
I didn't mean to offend the Queen.
Whatever the fuck I'm supposed to say.
Uh,
added a late show in Minneapolis on June 29th.
we added a late show and Seattle July 15th,
or it's the other ones.
What other ones?
All right.
Whatever.
You'll see all this shit.
You'll see all this shit where I'm going to be at.
Um,
oh man.
Wow.
This,
this is going to be a fun year.
It's going to be a fun year.
All right.
Enough with me fucking drooling over all those great places I get to perform at
Boston sports.
Hey,
they had Billy Russell.
Do you think Boston is the type of city that could have supported two teams in
any sport?
Do you think it's something you could handle in the future?
Thanks and go fuck yourself.
Um,
well,
we had that opportunity way back in the day.
We had the,
uh,
let's see,
we had the,
uh,
the Boston Braves and the Boston Red Sox,
the Braves ended up leaving.
MMM.
I Dunno.
I gotta be honest with you.
I don't know how the Brooklyn Nets did it.
Okay.
We're all those people out there with nick fans and then all of a sudden the New
Jersey,
Nick's move out there and it just says Brooklyn and everybody just jumps on the
bandwagon and says,
fuck the Knicks.
I don't get that.
Yeah.
Especially if you're a long time suffering Knicks fan.
And then what if they win it?
You know,
even if the Brooklyn Nets when it,
it's not going to be the same.
You didn't fucking,
they showed during your life,
you know,
that's like the second wife.
You don't love her the way you love the first one because the first one went
bad,
I would think.
Right.
I don't know.
Um,
and then of course we had two football teams there for a minute.
We had the New England patriots and we had the Boston breakers in the USFL.
I went to a game against the Washington federals,
that Nickerson Nickerson field.
I know,
I know.
I don't,
you know,
this is the deal.
We don't need more than one team and every sport the Way New York does to try to
fucking win some championships.
I'm telling you,
the fucking New York Yankees or the sugar daddy of New York City,
I,
that's the reason why New York City is not looked upon as one of the most
pathetic fucking sports towns ever.
Just conspired considering the amount of titles versus the amount of fucking
teams.
Um,
okay.
You know,
the next habit,
one in forever.
The Nets have never won the med seven one in 30 something years.
The jets have at one since Superbowl fucking three,
uh,
four wells.
The Knicks,
the Knicks since what 73?
Yeah.
The rangers have won one since 1940 and they're going on a 25 year fucking
drought again.
Uh,
they're about halfway through that fucking curse again already.
Just like that.
They went 54 years.
The last time.
They're almost at the halfway point of the,
um,
giants.
A decent giants are respectable.
Um,
and also they did a bar,
you know,
some giants also want some NFL titles too.
So,
um,
but what kills the fucking city for me,
aside from my blind hatred of them is the fact that,
you know,
you can just go,
oh,
what about the giants?
Cause you already have the jets so that you don't have to have the jets hanging
around your neck,
out the fucking meds a lot.
What about the Yankees?
You know what I mean?
They always have like a fucking option.
Um,
so yeah,
I dunno.
And I gotta be honest with you,
I don't understand how the clippers fucking survive,
but they do.
They do.
Um,
I just don't see that happening in a,
a city like Boston,
the size of it and the,
the ridiculous loyalty that you would bring a new team.
Like who the fuck would you bring in there?
I mean,
everybody hates us at this point in everybody's talked shit about us.
So what,
what are you going?
What are you,
who are you gonna move there?
The jag was the new England Jag was.
Okay.
What'd you put them on and oyster change their name.
The fucking Wister.
Willdabeast I dunno.
Former vegetarian and Auntie weight lifter.
A dear Billy bison thighs.
Heard you talking about lifting weights with Kenny Aronoff can I just read that
sentence again?
Heard you talking about lifting weights with Kenny Aronoff.
How fucking awesome was on the podcast.
I can't believe I got to meet that guy.
Really glad you understand the benefits.
I was a vegetarian who only did cardio for five and a half years.
I recently started eating animal fat again and I feel a lot better.
I'm not going to preach against Fredric [inaudible] vegetarianism,
but the mental benefits of those types of cholesterol is complete,
improved my hormone energy and cognitive levels.
I only eat grass fed meat and try to eat in the morning to improve brain
function.
Also,
since I started lifting weights once or twice a week,
my upper body feels better than when doing when doing basic tasks around the
house and yard.
Uh,
what's your take on red meat?
Are you picky where it comes from?
Nah,
dude.
I've literally,
I'll lead a fucking cow.
They need another cow.
I don't have,
I don't have the patients.
The,
there's a butcher,
you know,
a couple of towns over,
I guess I could go to sometimes I go there,
but generally speaking I don't know what I'm eating.
Um,
but I try to eat as well as I can.
Uh,
what's my take on red meat?
It's fucking delicious.
Um,
you know,
I start to read up on all of that shit.
It just gets so fucking depressing.
So I try me and then he goes to that,
they just say it's grass fed.
Okay.
So it's grass fed.
Everything sends.
It's fucking organic.
It isn't organic.
It's got a bunch of crap put in there like
the system to monitor what's in your food.
Like most systems at this point is so fucking corrupt.
Um,
I don't,
I don't know how to,
I don't know what to do,
but uh,
yeah,
I'm actually,
I will go back to lifting weights.
I don't think I'm going to do like bench pressing.
I'll do it with dumbbells for some reason with dumbbells.
I can control the angle independently on both shoulders and I don't have a
fucking problem.
But a bench pressing is for a young people and I am not young.
All right.
For Mont Gun Laws Bill,
I'm from New Hampshire and I always found it fascinating how lenient for months
gun laws are.
Here's a basic rundown of how Bernie runs things and why he's always careful
around the gun law conversation.
A minimum age to pursue,
purchase and possess in Vermont,
Vermont allows any person age 16 or older to possess a handgun without the
consent of a parent or Guardian.
There is no minimum age to possess a rifle or a shotgun in Vermont.
Fremont law allows firearm sales to anyone.
16 years or older.
Thanks.
All right,
well I really don't have a problem with any of that.
I just have a problem with people who are mentally ill getting them.
Uh,
that's the problem.
And nobody on either side seems to know how to stop that from happening.
You know the guy's the fucking people who buy guns keep making this is this guy
made this whole video showing how like this,
this rifle,
he had had a bullet twice the size of an ar 15 going,
but this is the,
this is the friendly gun.
Nobody's scared of this one and it's got a bolt twice cyber.
So you have to stop that and semi automatic.
You know what this saying?
You know what they're saying?
And everybody's just got to fucking just sit there and act like they don't
understand what the f doesn't.
Everybody want this shit to stop somebody for the love of fucking God.
Just come up,
figure out how to fuck you.
You can't be a fucking nutjob and just walk in and get a fucking gun.
That's the fucking problem.
But people who like to buy guns don't want it to be extra difficult for them to
get the fucking thing because they're not nuts.
So,
which is crazy to me.
I don't,
you know,
ah Ya,
Ya,
Ya.
But watching both of those arguments,
they're talking about two totally different fucking things.
One size,
just like cage free to have all of the guns.
Stupid.
Yeah.
Guns are great.
Guns do great things.
Okay?
They,
they do.
You keep defend yourself with a gun and you can provide,
you can hunt with a gun.
Okay?
You can scare somebody off with the fucking gun.
This is great fucking things.
And then there's bad things you could do with the gun.
Okay.
Um,
to Helen,
adventure.
Hell of an adventure.
All right,
wife on able to grow the fuck up.
Okay.
Hey there.
Billy said old sober ball sack.
Now I'm not sober anymore.
I got a rack,
a bud tall sitting in the fridge.
I love a Budweiser every once in a while and it can't,
it takes me back to when I first got shit faced down.
Faneuil Hall.
Uh,
Ben,
a listener for a few years.
Actually I was drinking Michelob light that night.
I'm a particular,
um,
I'm particularly a fan of the way you look at sensitive topics like religion.
Not everyone is able to question the fact of why all other religions sound
silly,
like our own.
I love that bit on your special.
Well thank you.
You know,
and as much as you loved it,
somebody else thought I was a servant of Satan.
Now for the question,
I'm a guy on my early thirties,
you mean in my early thirties.
Married with a boot with a beautiful two year old daughter.
Congrats on yours by the way.
It's a wonderful thing being a father.
Yes it is.
However,
my wife routinely gets nostalgic about her teenage years.
She's unable to get a steady job,
keeps changing topics.
It's,
it's school.
So she attends a certain course for a couple of years,
gives up heads onto the next one.
I was hoping becoming a mum would help,
but it looks like it hasn't recently.
She's even been asking how upset would I be if she told me she was cheating?
Oh,
what the fuck it,
that's it.
Uh,
she has apparently been watching some fucking show on Netflix where the
protagonist is a check that cheats to feel free and young again.
Yeah.
Oh my,
isn't it a fight?
It's just women.
I swear to fucking God.
I swear to God.
Okay.
Do you know if they have,
I put a show on the fucking air where a guy was cheating on his wife to feel
free and young again,
the amount of fucking attacks that that God damn show would get.
You know,
this is one thing that I have learned generally when it comes to women.
Okay.
If you fuck up,
it's your fault.
Okay.
It's your fault.
If they fucked up,
it's because it's something you did.
That's kind of how it works.
Um,
I told her,
I think that's bullshit.
I can go out on a guys' night out,
smoke a cigar,
and drink some alcohol and have a fucking great time.
And that's basically more than enough for me.
Unfortunately.
I have also found out she's been trying to engage in conversation with their
first big crush.
Oh boy.
Dude.
Like,
I,
you know,
you don't have to be a genius to read these tea leaves here,
man.
At least the way you're presenting it.
Okay.
So what's your takes on this?
What the fuck do I do with this woman?
We're planning on having a second child,
but honestly,
I'm not sure if it's a good idea.
It's fine for me to stay with my daughter and she can fuck off if that's what
she wants.
Uh,
I almost think you have to tell her that.
Find out first what's just be like,
what's going on with you.
You're asking me how I would feel if you cheated on me.
You watching this show with this woman's cheating and you're,
you're having conversations with your,
your first big crush.
Okay.
I need to know what's going on.
Are you going through a phase?
Because if this fucking things over,
it's fucking over.
I'm not having another kid with you.
MMM.
And I wouldn't get upset the way I'm getting upset for you to say it.
I would just put it on line like what's going on with you?
And,
um,
I don't know how much I would trust her.
Okay.
Listened to what she has to say.
And before,
uh,
I have another kid with that person,
I would fucking die.
I would hire a private investigator to follow around to see if she's not fucking
somebody else.
Uh,
no,
I wouldn't,
but you should.
Uh,
by the way,
you said I'm doing very well professionally and have also some hobbies that keep
me entertained.
Having a daughter certainly takes a toll on a relationship.
I'm guessing she's had,
she has too much free time and maybe consequently feels neglected.
We do try to watch a show every now and then and we'd go out as a family
regularly on the weekends.
Sex Life is okay.
Not sure if we can blame this situation on me.
Thanks a lot.
MMM.
Well,
God,
no,
she's gonna.
Yeah.
I mean,
what man does it feel fucking neglected to when they have a kid?
your sex life does suffer,
you know,
so that you then go out and,
do something to feel free and wanted.
MMM.
Yeah.
You need to sit down and talk to her.
Uh,
find out what the fuck is going on.
And I would just tell her what you're doing and the way you make me feel right
now is not even remotely fair and it's not something I would do to you.
So what the fuck?
Uh,
just clean that up.
Say it in a nice way.
Uh,
man,
it's fucking annoying.
Does a show out there where a woman flux around to feel free and young again?
Um,
listen,
here's the thing.
All right.
It's not that I even fucking mind that show because I believe that there are
people out there,
like there's people out there that they're just not designed to be married.
There's people out there that can actually do that and it doesn't mean shit to
him.
Both men and women and they can just fucking walk back in.
It doesn't mean shit to him.
The problem is the person they're with it means something too.
So,
um,
I'm pretty fucking open minded,
but uh,
I've just annoyed that if,
if you made a,
you know,
did they,
I guess it was Californication like that.
I have no idea.
I never watched that show.
I couldn't get into that show.
I didn't get what this guy's problem was.
Ah,
man.
You know,
these fucking young chicks just want to keep banging me.
I'm supposed to feel bad for this guy.
Um,
anyways,
friend's wife is attracted to me.
Jesus
dear billiard,
the cube bald,
the cue balls.
I like to appreciate the podcasts and everything you do and thank you for taking
the time to read this email.
No problem.
Thank you for the funny nickname.
I like it.
Uh,
I'm in a tricky situation here.
There are four people involved.
My Buddy of 12 years.
Oh man,
his wife of two years.
Dude,
where's your loyalty?
My girlfriend of six months and myself,
we're all in our mid to late twenties.
Oh boy.
Um,
is recently come to light that the wife is interested in me.
Oh Geez.
You just skipped over a lot of fucking details.
How did that come about?
She sent you a Valentine.
Oh,
you guys having inappropriate conversation that led to that end.
He was,
I met her about three years ago.
Why she and my buddy were still just dating.
She was my type and I was drawn to her immediately.
She is at least a nine for my tastes,
but I just put her in the unattainable compartment in my brain.
Since she wasn't available,
I did not give her any additional thought beyond being cordial.
I didn't really care to get to know her and I didn't think about what it would
be like to date her though she had been single.
I would have gone after it.
All right,
so so far,
according to you,
you've been a good guy.
Fast forward to the recent past.
My Buddy's wife and I got to know each other on a bit more of a personal level.
On my birthday a few months ago,
my girlfriend was there too and it seemed like my bud's wife took an interest in
getting to know my girlfriend as well.
Since then,
the four of us have hung out a few times and the wife has gotten to know me a
lot better.
Okay.
I've also been hitting the gym,
which has gotten the attention of my buddy's wife.
Ah,
Jesus Christ.
Okay.
All right.
They'd been married two years,
your 20s in your late twenties.
So she's looking to pull the ripcord.
Okay.
MMM.
Where the fuck was I?
Yeah.
Okay.
So one weekend a group of people including myself and my buddy's wife.
Yeah.
Go to a club.
My girlfriend was invited but decided to go to sleep instead.
Obviously alcohol was flowing and there isn't much room on a dance for I'll
spare you the details.
Do what do you mean?
Spare me the details?
It was just getting good.
Fuck what the fuck.
This is like a a Cinemax movie.
I'll spare you the details and suffice to say that I learned that night that she
was into me.
Yeah.
Uh,
when,
what she was doing the running man on your Dick.
I don't know what.
Okay.
I was pretty overwhelmed and thrilled because I thought she was a bit out of my
league and I'm also,
I'm also am not the happiest in my relationship.
What makes it harder for me to sort out my feelings on the matter.
This girl likes cells in the areas that my girlfriend doesn't am.
I certainly am very attracted to her and enjoy this type of attention.
I didn't know if she was unhappy in a relationship of what I've tried to see
what this girl wants or if there's a problem with their marriage,
but she has had a lot of dodgy answers,
like I wasn't looking for anything or this isn't supposed to go anywhere,
or I'm perfectly happy in my relationship,
et cetera.
She also has a hard time committing to any boundaries of fuck this chick.
Fuck this chick.
Or maybe she just got drunk and said something stupid.
Yeah.
It all sounds like bullshit to me.
I think she is lacking affection from my buddy and she's bored and Horny.
She also sounds like she just doesn't want to admit that there's a problem.
She's trying to have the security of a marriage and the thrill of a new romance.
We haven't kissed or anything yet big word yet,
but I feel like we've already desecrated both of our relationships.
I also feel like any increased fun,
talk about it and the tension will eventually reach the inevitable breaking
point.
Yeah.
You gotta stay away from her.
What should I do?
My girlfriend will lose her shit.
If she hears about this.
My buddy will be really unhappy.
I think you flipped those.
Okay.
I think you girlfriend be unhappy.
Your Bro,
your buddy.
We'll re lose his shit.
Okay.
Um,
anyways,
and I already feel like I couldn't trust this girl if we did get together.
However,
I don't really care.
I just loved the hookup with her.
I can,
while it's honest,
I could tell this girl has something wacky going on,
but I don't have the strength to reject her advances.
What should I do?
Thank you so much and go fuck yourself.
I stopped going out to the club with them or fucking rub one out before you go
out or don't drink when you go out there.
Yeah,
that's going to blow up.
That is going to fucking blow up
and your face.
Um,
but who's kidding who,
man,
that type of shit happens all the fucking time.
All the fucking time.
Married women will come up to another guy and say that they're attracted to
them.
I mean there's all this shit out there now about guy's behavior and that type of
shit.
Um,
you know,
women do it all the fucking time and they say they're better at it.
I don't think they necessarily are.
I think what the thing is,
is that just women are into vengeance.
So you know,
you know,
if,
if he gets like something like that going and if the end,
if they don't get a fucking check for $1 million in a house,
they're going to try to do something to blow up your life.
That's what they do guys.
We walk away.
Fuck you.
Booch and we just,
we've generally speaking,
we just,
we walk away.
They,
they don't,
they burned down your fucking life.
Um,
so,
uh,
dude dairy,
first of all,
break up with the fucking check you're with now and go find somebody else to
fuck around with.
All right?
You don't need to be fucking around with your buddies,
unhappy wife.
Um,
cause you're never going to be able to trust her.
All right.
Do you just not,
and then you're going to lose your friendship at 12 years with this other guy.
All right?
This is basically,
um,
like your Dixon Congress right now.
Like filibustering,
you know
your deck has the floor right now.
That's what the problem is.
If you just sit down,
okay.
And you listed all the pros and cons of doing this.
If you are aware,
I was at right now sitting there,
the answer is easy.
Don't do that.
But when your rented and your deck is there,
all fucking logic goes out the fucking window.
So,
um,
you know,
uh,
I dunno,
I just,
you know,
I,
I would just fucking,
she said there's nothing else to it.
I would leave it at that and if she brings it up again,
I would just say,
look,
you said there was nothing to it.
Okay.
So I don't want to hear any more of that kind of talk.
I already did it.
You can't hang out with her anymore.
You can't,
you cannot fucking hang out with her unless that dude is there.
And if this guy is really a fucking friend,
by the way,
wait a minute.
If this guy is really your friend,
you know,
you wouldn't be thinking about doing that.
And B.
Okay.
Oh Man,
I don't know if you tell him.
I don't know if he should tell.
I wouldn't tell him it's a fucking mess.
You know a woman would.
Women would,
okay.
Women would initiate the conversation and then turn around and fucking tee,
you know?
Yeah.
Don't tell him.
Don't tell them.
That's a stupid fucking idea cause she,
she'll flip the fucking story,
start crying,
he'll feel bad and he's going to choose her over you.
Dude,
you got a situation.
There's just so many fucking ways that this can go and none of it's good unless
you just walk away,
walk away,
go back to the wrong.
Go back to the wrong fucking sad moment in fucking when you're playing cards,
we just kind of admit,
you're not going to win tonight.
Just fucking cash out and go back to the fucking room.
That's what you should do.
A jerk off tours.
As much as you fucking want to get it out of your system.
Go find somebody else that you like that makes you not to think about your
buddy's wife.
How about that?
There?
There we go.
Um,
but I'm sure she just wants to feel free.
All right.
I know I was a little bit of an asshole,
but what are you gonna do?
All right.
That's the podcast.
Um,
once again,
thank you very much.
It came out in Vancouver and I'm going to be in Ontario coming up this weekend
on the 17th.
Wherever the fuck I'm going to be.
I came up against when Al,
I think it's up on my website.
Bill Bill bird.com.
That's the podcast.
Go fuck yourselves and I'll check in on you on Thursday.